unhappiness is a result of pain on
demand right pain on demand like Netflix
of unhappiness it's basically you saying
you know what happened last Friday let
me play that again
aha and suffering it from it and then
let me add a little bit to it right so
your boyfriend says something or
girlfriend says something harsh on
Friday you go on Sunday and say let me
remember that and cry mm-hmm and then on
Monday you go yeah he doesn't love me
anymore and then on Tuesday you say oh
damn I hate dating and then you go like
Oh on you on Wednesday I'm gonna spend
the rest of my life alone and you just
can't build as much drama as you want
around it it's all happened last Friday
and by the way he's not gonna show up
and apologize right so you can be
unhappy for as long as you want until
you tell him or her that you're unhappy
nothing's gonna happen right so what is
useful now and by the way this is this
is something I call the suffering cycle
the suffering cycle is actually quite
straightforward I don't know if you have
one of those friends that wake up in the
morning and feel super excited so they
call you at 8:00 a.m. because they have
been awake since 6:00 and they really
want to tell you something right and so
they call you at 8:00 a.m. you don't
answer so they call at 8:01 you don't
answer so they call at 8:03 and they you
don't answer and then they text you and
then they call again and act like I have
to talk to them right and then at 8:15
you go like can I call you at 10:00
right and they say sure and shut up
right that's exactly what your brain
does it tells you hey by the way your
partner said something harsh on Friday
you don't do anything about it
so it makes you feel unhappy and then
you don't do anything about it so your
brain says that they can and so you feel
unhappy and you do nothing about it and
so your brain says it again and again
and again and again is that useful in
any way that cycle wastes your effort
wastes your time waste your energy right
and it leads to nothing at all right
it's triggered by nothing because the
event happened last Friday at least the
cortisol which actually kills you
exactly right so so so that the reality
is that cycle truly declines your
ability to solve the problem
right to actually engage and and and and
that's that's really what why we say
that unhappiness is good for you know no
pain is good for you pain is good for
you because it alerts you that you need
to learn something you need to change
something you need to take action you
need to change direction pain is good
suffering is it so Ali died Ali died
means I could have closed my door and
cried for the rest of my life truly and
if you had hugged Ali once I guarantee
you you wouldn't blame me he was an
angel he was unbelievable he was
everything he was my coach my son I
always say it was my son and my son
right now what good would that be at my
deathbed he would still not be here
right and and I know it sounds really
unfeeling no no I I cry every time I
remember him I I do but what good is
that now suddenly you start to tell
yourself so I feel the pain and prom I
promise you the one thing that changed
my life is I found a way to take that
pain every single morning and turn it
into I'm gonna go out there and make
another thousand people happy right can
you actually do that can you actually
say like the Sun - right Scott so can
you take the pain because pain is coming
from outside you and instead of turning
it into incessant thinking that just
tortures you turn it into energy that
makes the world a better place and and I
have clear examples of that every
morning
I have a very simple deal with my brain
I have a deal that says target a deal oh
it's really straightforward on you have
you have to understand this the thoughts
in your head are not you write the
thoughts in your head I are a biological
function this is your brain producing
and a concept that you can understand in
English am i safe do i a food
sweep it's basically processing
everything there is an MIT study that is
incredible you should look at it 2009 it
had MRI studies giving people word
puzzles right and they basically asked
them to solve problems the problem was
solved in a few
based on how complex the problem is and
then the verbal Association engine of
your brain the part that actually lights
up when you speak out loud starts to
blink for up to eight seconds and then
the participant would know the answer so
the brought the brain actually solves
the problem first and then takes eight
seconds to turn it to English so that
you understand it right it's a
biological function how how many of you
wake up every morning and tell yourself
I am blood you know the biological
function of your heart is to pump blood
around your body you don't call yourself
blood no one calls themselves urine
right seriously you know biological
function of your kidney but somehow we
think that the thoughts in my head are
me talking to me if it was you talking
to you what why would you need to talk
like seriously right now one once you
realize that everything changes